[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette autre
édition d' espace autochtone en direct
je m'appelle anne-marie et vont alors
nous avons réuni vous le voyez déjà un
autre panel cette semaine pour parler
des lendemains de l'élection fédérale
donc le 21 octobre tout le monde est
allé aux urnes ou enfin beaucoup de
monde est là aujourd'hui nous allons
analyser ses résultats sous l'angle sous
la perspective autochtone avec isabelle
picard ethnologue bonjour isabelle
danjou mairie avec alexis wawanoloath
qui est un ancien député du parti
québécois dans abitibi est
bonjour alexis coué est riche quinn qui
est là aujourd'hui pour nous parler de
ce qui s'est passé chez les inuit fin
juin alors bonjour à tous les trois la
dernière fois qu'on s'était laissé elie
journée vous n'étiez pas là à ce moment
là mais bon je vous avais demandé vos
prévisions est ce que vous espériez
alors allez vous gagnez vos élections ou
enfin avez-vous aujourd'hui au pouvoir
ce que vous espériez
on parlait si je me souviens bien d'un
gouvernement minoritaire on l'espérait
en tout cas dans mon cas c'est le moins
pire des pires scénarios si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi
je pense que le gouvernement libéral
repos choix effectivement de faire des
alliances et ses alliances notamment
avec le npd
or on a vu que le npd est très sensible
aux questions autochtones tout au long
de la campagne
monsieur signer lui-même une minorité
visible donc je pense que ça va jouer
beaucoup aussi dans la suite des choses
moi j'attends des grandes choses des
prochains mondiaux dont beaucoup
d'attendus coup de mou ou alexis très
soulagé que les consommateurs est élu on
le lui durant la campagne
on ne voyait seulement sous la lorgnette
quand on était bon pour l'économie
quand des bruits au projet de
développement des ressources naturelles
d'aller extraire les ressources
naturelles
donc c'est quand même un poil moins sur
les impôts vont pouvoir continuer
d'avancer
c'est ce que le parti libéral a pas été
parfait mais justement comme on disait
les bébés qui est là avec les vins aussi
avec le bloc s'est montré ouvert aux
revendications des premières nations
je pense que ce choix là les libéraux
parole choix de de faire en sorte de
mieux nous écouter il ya deux mois alors
revenons sur les résultats
promenons-nous à travers le pays parce
qu'il ya quand même eu beaucoup de
candidats autochtone beaucoup plus qu'en
en 2015 on avait quoi 54 il y en a eu 62
en 2019
et pourtant dix seulement ont été élues
comme en 2015 à votre avis pourquoi
est-elle résultats pourquoi pas plus
d'autochtones ont été élus à travers le
pays
alexis la tête à cause du fait qu'on ne
me regardait des engins d'octobre dans
la
l'élection 2015 ça pour être une des
voies possibles peut-être aussi que les
promesses déçues les libéraux avaient
fait qu'ils ont notamment une déception
peut-être quelques mois une mobilisation
dans les comtés où le voter toner était
un portage et pas de réponses à court
terme selon la police c'est vraiment le
taux de votation chez les premières
nations jeu mais attend une baisse
cindy world qui était avec nous là la
dernière émission nous disait qu'elle
entendait beaucoup de gens qui étaient
un peu découragé des premières nations
qui disait je vais pas aller voter ce
que j'entendais pas à ce moment là mais
définitivement vers les derniers jours
de la campagne
il ya beaucoup d'autochtones alentours
de voix qui ont dit bon ça donne quoi tu
on nous écoute pas on avait été le
pendant la campagne
donc je pense que l'oeil le taux de
participation avoir baissé de o
et pourtant les certains chefs en tout
cas ont incité les gens à aller voter
on l'a vu sur les réseaux sociaux web on
a vu comme avec berry belgrade qui
faisait un appel au monde ce que j'ai vu
sur facebook
darmon facebook c'est beaucoup de chefs
même le jour du vin qui disait en
réaction à des plus jeunes qui disait de
beauté un [ __ ] ou des choses comme ça
des chefs qui disait allez voter libéral
ont une relation de confiance on a
travaillé avec lui pendant 4 ans à 6
considérablement millions us comparé à
l'époque que je pense que dans le
leadership autochtone ya un certain
soulagement le pull noir dans le jir
communiqué ou six au québec déchets
félicité sur les candidats libéraux qui
avaient gagné où le premier minis ce
donc à tout le monde est pris avec les
conservateurs pis la dent situation où
en est lyon risque d'avoir un peu plus
des clowns
les chefs on salué ce gouvernement
minoritaire là je pense que c'était
vraiment le meilleur des scénarios on le
veut un peu partout et j'ai noté aussi
une grande différence dans ce convoyage
sont les réseaux sociaux par rapport des
jeunes par rapport aux générations plus
âgées chez les premières nations les
jeunes s'étaient npd c'était un petit
peu parti vert mais beaucoup une [ __ ] et
chez les plus âgés
j'ai noté que c'est davantage un vote
pour les libéraux dans tout ça va être
intéressant
il va falloir voir aussi comment les
chefs vont être à l'écouté de ces jeunes
là oui je veux juste donner les codes et
des présidents ou président de l'union
des organisations inuites à travers
l'arctique
encore une séance de soulagement c'est
sûr vous voulu comme un gouvernement
majoritaire pour continuer le travail
mais il y aussi une inquiétude parce que
tout le monde se rencontre dans une cage
des gouvernements minoritaires
on est probablement vous on encore au
canada le moyenne d'un gouvernement
minoritaire c'est au tour de deux ans
oui soyons inquiets truc ça brise un peu
le loin ouais de devoir recommencer tout
dans deux ans deux ans et demi plus tard
la wii alors les grandes déceptions
avez vous eu de grande déception à la
suite de cette élection de ces élections
mais si j'en ai eu une de manière très
générale
j'étais surprise au niveau du nombre de
votes pour les verts ayant seulement au
niveau du vote populaire ils ont
recueilli seulement 6% des voix
avec tout ce qu'on a vu dans les
dernières semaines les marches greta
banquiers terreur je m'attendais à ce
que les verts aient cherché un petit peu
plus de votes
moi ça me suis venu c'est venu me
chercher je me suis dit que
l'environnement on n'était peut-être pas
encore rendus là où on devrait parce que
c'est ma déception du sommet ue chine
sous performance la campagne était
vraiment pas
au niveau haut niveau c'est à dire des
déceptions au québec jean rémy voire
plus d'un candidat autochtone de la part
de toutes les parties y en a eu deux
comme tout le soudan ta chronique cette
semaine xavier watts au kenya un coup à
beynac et un coup nationale - et 1
jacqueline rouleau à qui vient de sa
mère dans abitibi baie james nunavik
eeyou est bel et bon mais xavier
s'entendait paul faisait sa pelouse par
contestation oui mais dans les quatre
grands partis d'enfance il y avait déjà
trois quatrièmes places c'est très
simple
pour les autochtones du québec pour rien
en particulier pour un compte et aussi
comme abitibi baie james nunavik eeyou
qui a tellement de réalité de la est
représentée elle s'arrêter le folk
peut-être qu'il ya eu un petit peu plus
d'efforts de la part des autres partis
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors mais
j'imagine que des cernets de 4 à 6
avions refusé l'avenir d'autres choses à
faire mais en même temps c'est qu'elle
est fort qu'on fait pour aller chercher
d autres acteurs moi aussi j'ai été élu
à l'époque parti québécois c'était pas
une volonté du parti québécois de
m'avoir c'était moins que remonter de
l'association dans la circonscription
c'est moi de ce qui m'est imposé piégée
qui te toute limite à l'ouverture puis
je me suis glissé au travail finalement
me retrouvais députés s'étaient pas la
volonté quand même date parti québécois
d'avoir une attaque tonnes dindar son
goût et pour travailler pour tous les
citoyens qui travaillent le tableau
j'avais eu à faire face à cette période
et citoyens que j'allais je sais trés
député des hautes octobre tandis que je
pense que j'ai fait un gros travail des
avants pour pour tout le monde oui oui
oui
chez les inuit hellich qu'est ce qui a
déçu les inuit au terme de ces élections
mais encore je pense que ça prend du
temps de métaboliser les résultats de
cette élection en particulier comme on a
parlé de la situation ici au québec dans
la circonscription avec l'unique c'est
resté le même outil hainaut et puis à
labrador où les inuits
il fait partie d'une circonscription
sa caste et les bars à donner de qom est
vraiment le résultat choc choc c'est ce
qui est arrivé au nunavut
oui et c'est comme on sait pas
exactement pourquoi on insère 11 août à
la com vous avez dit isabelle séquelles
sondages mais il faut se rappeler le
capital politique que le gouvernement
trudeau a mis dans les relations avec
les inuits du canada
les dernières quatre ans comme j'ai noté
juste quelques items avant de venir ici
mais il ya des comités de partenariat
entre les animaux d'el cajon une
protocole qui est signé entre le
gouvernement et peuple outil qui est l
organisation des femmes inuites du
canada il ya toutes sortes de choses qui
est sorti de ses partenariats
un clan pour le double qu'il ose des
promesses pour les logements
oui et c'est énorme et nous nous vous
êtes le seul que sa conception avec une
population maintenant à majorité inuite
ils ont rejeté complètement on ne sait
pas est ce que c'est ça qu'il faut voir
et plus ça soulève plus de questions que
les réponses à ce moment là mais c'est
extraordinaire et surtout parce que
madame marquis qui est gagné et la poule
elle est juste une équipe des bénévoles
qui je travaillais pour qu'ils avaient
trop mais c'est aussi le contexte de
tous les capitales pour l'éthique numéro
et dans les terribles circonscription
mais en plus cette équipe de bénévoles
il était capable de gagner contre les
machines débarrasser extraordinaire et
c'est la première fois que l'un des 10
et cani de ça fait presque 40 ans mais
il est vraiment remarquable
oui mais est-ce que ça serait pas le
seul entrepreneur qui par an est-ce que
ce serait pas justement que la relation
que la candidate et son équipe à dix
avec le territoire est peut-être plus
importante que toute la machine libérale
que tous les services qu'on peut avoir
cette relation là que les plusieurs
autochtones et inuits on sentit brisée
dans le dernier mandat de monsieur
trudeau on avait bien commencé mais à la
fin ça c'est vraiment est nettement
effritées
donc est-ce que ça serait pas où il ya
eu des services mais est ce que la
relation n'est pas plus importante aussi
à quelque part à long terme way pour
avoir une confiance mais c'est très
intéressant aussi parce que c'est ce que
comme je ne lis tu j'ai pas comme un
hacker de mix on sait que les anecdotes
mais quand je vais sur le terrain dans
l'arctique pas nouveau tout nunavik et
une sans spoil les gens je dirais les
dirigeants d'organisation ni ride c'est
pas ça du tout mais les chasseurs et les
chasseuses dans les communautés les
personnes qui travaillent dans les
cohortes en arctique pour une édition et
j'ai pas une personne comme ça qui me
dit que paula réconciliation veut dire
quelque chose parce que dans ma
communauté
y'a rien qui ait changé je me demande
aussi comme je dis on va voir un petit
peu dans les semaines qui s'en vient
mais beaucoup de gens disent c'est comme
si je vois pas j'ai comme il 4900
personnes qui attendent un logement au
nunavut
mais il rien ne change et c'est quand
même d'avoir les enfants seuls les
logements et il est rare qu'ils osent
mais je vois pas les choses qui changent
sur le terrain dans leur vie de george
white boy d'améliorer l'accès au
territoire pour la chasse peu tout le
temps et vous engager
donc dans leur vie quotidienne y a pas
eu de changement puis je pense que ces
îlots qu'une candidate au mudac khattak
parce qu'il a bien prononcé a réussi à
aller toucher des gens justement pions
le vue ou si c'est une activiste qui le
qu'on attend depuis plusieurs années
qu'ils avaient fait il ya quelques
années un discours suber les mouvements
baissiers sur sept succès par la chambre
des communes
donc c'est quelqu'un qui a ses racines
dans le militantisme dans la défense des
intérêts dans la vie tous les jours loin
et aussi quand il ya eu le débat entre
les candidats ou nouveau jeu s'est passé
vous avez regardé ça mais c'était
vraiment frappant mais je pense aussi
cette idée de parler directement avec
les électeurs parce que nous allions et
aglukkaq ans un ancien ministre dans le
gouvernement de rappeur puis on à madame
pitt seul ayo qui étaient les candidats
pour les libérales et ils ont beaucoup
parlé de ce qui était dans le programme
de manama q qu'est ce qu'elle a fait
pendant qu'ils étaient dans notre
gouvernement conservateur et madame
marque était toujours y ait rien qui
change
les suicides dans ma communauté c'est
encore lui et c'était vraiment différent
juste la façon que les communiqués et on
se demande comme vous avez dit peut-être
c'était la relation elle jeunes gens se
sont sentis trahis l'abc important là on
est tannés des promesses non tenues
finalement c'est peut-être une partie du
message au nunavut
c'est sûrement quelque chose quitte à
lui ben winnipeg centre où on avait deux
candidats docteur oui la nique aux votes
des circonscriptions lieu plus de tels
thèmes plus grosse concentration
d'autres acteurs
c'est un noël est content né à gaza et
au bout de la ligne qui a remporté c'est
l'un des délais à gaza justement dans ce
cas les gens sur le terrain qui vit tout
les jours d'abstinence longtemps
toujours des changements on voit pas
nécessairement dans les communautés ces
changements louis des communautés qui en
vaut pas table mais atik lyon ils sont
encore obligés d'aller dans le bloc
sanitaire sont encore obligés d'aller
chercher leurs groupies ils se sont dit
que son discours a tant sur leur propre
territoire
oui il invite tous les jours les gens ne
voient pas et aussi comme vous avez dû
négocier c'est c'est la question d'avoir
un candidat qui dit pas un nom tout est
correct c'est comme non les choses
marchent bref c'est quelque chose je
pense les gens sont rendus là où il veut
que quelqu'un constate que noël ça
change pas il ya une grande franchise de
sa part d'ailleurs
sadki qui a décidé de ne pas se bander
les yeux mais de dire ben oui on observe
la réalité on va tout faire pour la
changer finalement alors on parlait des
déceptions mais est ce qu'il y a est ce
qu'il ya eu de bonnes nouvelles à
travers ce que vous avez vu dans les
nominations dans des personnes qui ont
été élus est ce que vous avez comme les
magasins ne peut-être est-ce que vous
voyez comme ça est ce qu'on peut parler
de jaude et avec jodie wickett un peu
délaissé parce qu'évidemment étant
arrivé tout seul sans parti autour
d'elle pour pour la montée mais au
contraire toute seule elle s'est
débrouillée toute seule elle a été élue
alors oui ça a été ça fait quand même en
étant au niveau du débat et vote je me
souviens moment donné je commence à être
fatigué et eh oui allez oui puis on
sentait tout le monde on s'écrivait puis
on sentait qu'il y avait vraiment
voulait qu'elle soit là je pense que
c'est un symbole fort c'est un message
important je pense au gouvernement de
justin trudeau
maintenant j'ai bien de voir comment va
se débrouiller dans tout ça mais il ya
quelque chose que c'est passé l'âge je
crois parce que c'est quand même nom
vancouver ou annuels ne sais pas oui il
ya des autochtones mais je voudrais on
n'est quand même pas à north bay août
c'est donc il ya quelque chose
elle était aussi élu par des non
autochtones dans will you quelque chose
que oui en milieu urbain absolument
c'est de voir justement qu est ce qu un
député indépendant de votre capable de
faire dans ce contexte le yoyo beaucoup
de travail d'influencé caveau pouvoir
faire mais c'est un peu les nerfs
l'absurdité de notre système
parlementaire
ou quand on oppose deux partis
politiques où on ne monte à paroles on a
moins d'argent pour faire vos recherches
ont le moins d'argent pour faire le
travail parlementaire mais bon j'espère
que ça va voir l'effet d'au moins un
revendeur quelques quelqu'un qui va
rappeler
c'est quoi les les prix en dépit pour
lesquelles il a été élu que pour qu'elle
serait arrivé si jamais ils respectent
pas les les autochtones que la franchise
qu'on doit avoir en faisant de la
politique parce que c'est un peu ce que
là on a voulu sauver une compagnie on a
eu une franche personnes qui voulaient
appliquer la loi donc c'était une
présence symbolique très importante à
tout moment si j'étais très content mais
après ce dans la réalité politique de
notre système parlementaire britannique
j'espère qu'elle va pouvoir faire un
travail important est ce que ça va juste
se faire à l'intérieur du travail
peut-être que justement sont le fait
qu'elle a été réélu vont continuer de
lui permet d'avoir une plate forme pour
pouvoir s'exprimer
qu'est ce qu'elle peut avoir comme appui
qui peut l'appuyer parce qu'il ya quand
même plusieurs partis maintenant à la
chambre des communes justin trudeau est
minoritaire donc chacun à une plus
grande voix mais elle est encore toute
seule là dedans mais bon je pense qu'au
delà du fait qu'elle soit une femme
autochtone
elle symbolise aussi l'intégrité
aujourd'hui c'est extrêmement important
et je pense que des partis qui ont si
l'intégrité au coeur de leur programme
aucun à leurs valeurs de leur mission
comme le npd par exemple
je pense qu'ils vont pouvoir venir la
supporter que je l'espère grandement
ouais mais encore un vol on en voit
aussi dans les chiffres et j'aime rouler
show chic en colombie britannique est
toujours très populaire du fait que
c'est une ancienne cherche des
régionales donc je pense que dans les
communautés autochtones marchi de la
colombie-britannique est une bombe
il y en a puisque j'ai vu aussi c'est à
travers le canada les usa ni
suffisamment passage dans les centres
d'amitié à travers le canada coast to
coast si tout le monde était heureux de
voir ce fake c'est un symbole qui est la
pierre en voir l'appui déjà deux
premières réactions je pense de tout
pays
alors on va revenir à hellich tout à
l'heure on parlait d'ondés des grandes
quatre grandes régions où il y a des
inuit et on parlait entre autres bancs
de la défaite de jacqueline rouleau mais
me vous vouliez je pense vous exprimer à
ce sujet là parce que ça a changé 1 dans
ce petit bibi james nunavik oui je le
dis il vaut mieux ça ghana puis c'est le
bloc québécois qui est rentré et c'est
intéressant parce que les gars du
nouveau-brunswick puis menacé à vous
tous qui est dans l'arbre d'or et
maintenant on voit les différents
régions où on se trouve les inuits c'est
les représentants les députés de
différents partis so on allait libéral
au labrador bloc québécois
si au québec npd à une nouveauté puis un
libéral au piano oui mais les
organisations l'ignoré dit que c'est pas
une mauvaise chose parce que dit que
toutes les trois partis c'est assez
gauche et des polypes lors qu'on peut
trouver sur les événements ils sont une
question est que même ses députés sont
différents que ne voit pas que ça va
causer des problèmes de faire avancer
les dossiers qui sont importants pour
elle il est en ce moment
oui mais pour les cris et les inuits qui
vivent dans cette grande région là ça
doit être une déception de voir entrer
une non autochtone à damas avec moi les
attentes
si je pense pas qu'elle grand monde à 20
quand elle veut malgré la la la la
qualité de la candidature face à l'état
des choses que 20 comme on le voyait au
québec avoir quelqu un candidat npd
rentrée le le sort en général de cette
circonscription doivent au plus avec de
terminer à val d'or qui s'entend bien
qu'avec l'art mais aussi les différents
voyez que aux dernières élections 2015
c'était majorité libérale au sud une
fois qu'on est arrivé notre communauté
autochtone des les décomptes ont
commencé à rentrer fort pour roméo
mais bon il reste que c'est cela la
majorité de ce nom autochtone au bar les
psy il serait étonnant qu'il y avait des
attentes à ce que j'ai en clair soit élu
donc au niveau des attentes il devrait
pas y en avoir d tellement serré
c'est sûr que on perd quelqu'un qui
était très efficace au niveau de la
défense des droits des peuples
autochtones avec roméo
je pense qu'on le vus comme un roméo a
été célébrée à chez les premières
nations que les autochtones qu'on a
perdu quand même quelqu'un qui avait une
voix forte qui avait amené la
déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones de l'onu au parlement donc
ils sont l'héritage de rester les
libéraux se sont engagés à poursuivre
dans cette voie le npd ou six mais sous
celle de la perte de remo dont un vent
de déception oui alors et elie
j'aimerais qu'on poursuive à ce sujet là
parce que ça serait le fun ii
on parlait tout à l'heure d'un
gouvernement minoritaire pour beaucoup
ça plaît mais pas nécessairement pour
tout le monde il ya eu des réactions à
ce sujet oui mais c'était tous les
questions comme on dit tout à l'heure
que ça va on regarde vraiment de
prochaine deux ans et le travail comme
on a parlé de prendre ma dernière quatre
ans tous les ans tant que les intentions
mais c'est sûr ça prend beaucoup de
temps de réaliser
et puis on sait sur une double moment
routière dans deux ans les gouvernements
et les gens qui travaillent c'est aussi
là ils sont pas en train de regarder
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans quatre
ans parce que c'est savent que ça va pas
arriver à carouge oui c'est ça les links
et tulle c'est les dossiers ce que ça va
être un peu
les états us pour les prochaines deux
ans où est-ce qu'ils aient les gestes
réels qui va être posée pour acide
avancer ses dossiers et toutes ses
enfants qui étaient signés avec les
organisations inuites
alors l'ancien nouveau premier ministre
du canada a dit qu'il allait faire plus
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour vous
qu'est ce que vous voyez à travers le
faire plus faire plus pour les
autochtones
c'est de ça c'est ce qui le dit oui oui
ben je pense qu'il ya certaines choses
qui va être probablement capable de
rendre à terme c'est à dire notamment
l'accès à l'eau potable pour tous sont
venus à dire il reste encore 56 comme
notre autochtone sans accès à l'eau
potable
le npd c'était clair donc je pense pas
qu'il y aura des freins ou des bâtons
dans les roues à ce niveau là je pense
qu'on va pouvoir y arriver maintenant
faire plus c'est dans la relation il
faut vraiment qu'ils rebâtissent assez
trop effrité dans les dernières années
et on s'est rendu compte que ben il peut
être que si en fait en fait j'ai envie a
aussi parlé du pipeline elle-même dans
la sphère où l'offre quand même dans le
sujet mais il lui ce qu'il dit c'est que
il réitère en fait tout dernièrement
dans post élections et réitère ce qui le
dit avant les élections c'est qu' il
veut aller de l'avant avec la décision
d'agrandir le lion duc tuân ce matin et
ce qu'il dit surtout c'est que
environnement et économie doivent aller
de pair alors s'agir de voir comment
avec ce il veut capable de faire plus
souhait mais peut-être que entre autres
en ce qui concerne le pipeline ça va
peut-être rallier des communautés
autochtones de l'alberta entre autres
plusieurs sont pour le pipeline pour la
construction de ce pipeline na waie mais
je comprends mais à réelle politique
faut essayer d'aller chercher notre
majorité puis même en achetant un
pipeline même en étant super ouvert à
l'exportation des sables bitumineux à
l'exploiter l'exploitation de cette
ressource le lieu prévu un siège en
alberta est ce que monsieur trudeau
c'est le travail et à défendre l'unité
canadienne puis pas trop faire peur aux
albertains où il veut vraiment aller
rechercher une majorité
évidement très chiant je pense en ce
moment pour atteindre 170 je pense pas
que ça va le bertone qui va aller
chercher tracy hp spot et en
saskatchewan qui va les chercher 13
sièges donc des ces sujets là on peut
vont plus à interpeller déjà de la
colombie-britannique du canada québec
ontario par rapport aux employés et si
aller chercher cette même ajouté je
pense que ça serait un des éléments sur
lesquels ils devraient reculer ayant
faim plus celle ci pourrait alors faire
plus pour voile etc si ça veut dire quoi
aubin en justice qu'est ce que vous
attendez à justice les femmes
autochtones implique vraiment toutes les
recommandations puis qu'on aille plus
loin que ça pour aller faire en sorte
que nos soeurs je me fie à les mêmes
opportunités dans la vie pierre
l'opportunité de pas mourir vous un
droit humain bons basiques impressionne
sur une représentation dans le système
carcéral je pense qu'il serait important
que toutes les initiatives de
réappropriation de nos justice
traditionnelle devraient être mises de
l'avant
il ya des projets qui se font dans ce
sens l'on voit chez les êtres humains
qu'on le voit chez les noirs et
l'expérience et des attikameks sur 43
ans quand même depuis quelques années je
suis trois récidive camp de prière en
fonction la justice traditionnelle
mais comment on est allé voir c'est quoi
les sources du problème justement au
fait pour intégrer cette personne donc
je pense que ceci rend temps qu'avec la
manche au coût de 10 devrait être des
éléments devront faire plus fort plus
dans la décolonisation
c'est ce que j'entends aussi des
colonisés les systèmes c'est à dire les
mettre à terre et les rebâtir autrement
histoire ça va demander un effort
considérable mais je pense que sa belle
chanson sur la réconciliation qu'on a
entendu pendant quatre ans l'ol joue
plus à la radio donc il faut aller
ailleurs je pense qu'on est rendu le
nous mêmes comme premières nations comme
un autochtone on achemine et puis je
pense qu on comprend que si on veut
changer les choses mais il faut vraiment
les mettre à terre et les rebâtir dans
une décolonisation le qui m'apparaît
essentiel
est-ce qu'il vous entendra vous pensé
quand vous dites ça ben il ya des voix
il n'y a pas le choix d'attendre
d'entendre des voix plus à gauche comme
je l'expliquais un peu plus tôt il faut
pas aller chercher ça va je donne
alberta donc je pense que s'ils veulent
réellement aller chercher juste dans une
perspective à court terme électoraliste
devrait nous entamons donc
juste pour être opportuniste devrait
nous entendre puis par la suite si est
vraiment sincère
qu'est ce qui dit qui veut parler de
réconciliation ça serait la moindre des
choses qui se met vraiment maxi oui
qu'est ce qu'on attend de lui
chez dans les grands organisation inuit
mais pour le moment je dirais que c'est
de gueule de bois vraiment les gestes
posés dans la communauté pour que le
monsieur et madame tous les jours voir
les changements tient toujours à sa oui
oui et puis je pense comme vous avez dit
un petit peu le lancier chanson ça
marche plus il faut passer par d'autres
choses aussi trop il était le seul chef
de parti qui est allé en arctique et
kalou 8 pendant les campagnes
électorales puis le premier que toutes
les communautés qui va travailler pour
que tout le monde soit maintenant plus
le petro mais juste l'énergie verte
d'ici je pense et 2030
oui mais sont les détails sais où je
pense les gens nathan comme une feuille
de route
exactement c'est quand les logements
vont être bâtis ou comment et tout ça
mais c'est vraiment les gestes du bloc
solide et puis oui c'est ça et je pense
aussi que l'arctique les gens aussi
entendre parce que toutes les
organisations onu a dit que c'est sûr
qu'on a besoin des choses dans nos
communautés mais l'article ça fait
partie du projet national du canada et
toutes les questions les contaminants
dans l'arctique
le changement climatique est dit c'est
vraiment un enjeu c'est sûr nous les
agneaux et on est comme la au franklin's
mais c'est un enjeu pour tout le pays et
s'étaient pas abordé dans les campagnes
électorales ayant eux mêmes
un groupe d'académique qui en fait une
étude sur l'activité sur les réseaux
sociaux pendant les campagnes
électorales et le dernier fois que j'ai
vu les chiffres c'était le 15 octobre et
au juste 7 8 qui parlait d un web social
actuel - les enjeux au niveau de son
vraiment fait pas par des leçons c'est
assez rare oui elle aimerait que ça
vienne plus comme pas juste un enjeu n 8
mais comme ça se voit plus comme une
partie du le projet canadien oui alors
on disait c'est un gouvernement
minoritaire donc le premier ministre n'a
pas le choix de travailler avec les
autres chefs de parti npd bloc québécois
aussi au québec pour les autochtones
quel intérêt de se tourner vers le bloc
québécois pour aller chercher des acquis
par exemple j'ai envie de laisser aller
premièrement il ya l'intérêt d'avoir son
député de pouvoir aller voir son député
directement de pouvoir mettront les
défis parce que c'est des dons aussi
qu'ils sont de compétence fédérale bons
de travail de députés ces deux souvent
d'accompagner les citoyens - c'est
qu'est ce que je faisais beaucoup à
l'époque j'étais député j'ai accompagné
les citoyens dans des dossiers de santé
de csst des choses comme ça qui était de
compétence provinciale donc il ya
beaucoup d'autochtones qui vont se
tourner en dernier recours qu'à dans la
communauté n'ont pas de réponse non pas
de société civile sur laquelle dénoncer
les injustices
je vais beaucoup de tact sommes servis
riva en dernier recours vers leur député
fédéral donc d'avoir déjà une porte
ouverte pour pouvoir revenir savoir
attendre les problèmes peut-être
justement cei travaille à ce qui se fait
de pire au dos n'a de sens d'un point de
vue macro il y aller
l'ouverture du bloc de travail et de
nation à nation de sortir du
paternalisme et il serait juste de la
moindre des cohérences pour le blog
justement d'être très ouvert une volonté
d'aider des nations autochtones parce
qu'ils se battent ils sont nationalistes
pour la nation québécoise
il veut plus de liberté ils veulent
éventuellement qu'on aille au québec
toutes les attributs tonetto donc la
logique même la cohérence même veut
qu'ils soient ouverts à l'autonomie à la
plus grande indépendance des peuples
autochtones à ce qu'on puisse justement
se définir nous mêmes qu'on arrête de se
faire définir par une loi sur les
indiens ou par des institutions ou
parler la société en général donc je
pense qu'on risque d'avoir un bon allié
dans ce sens le du fait qu' il ya cette
sensibilité deux atouts et le bloc
québécois représentent les québécois et
les québécois ont été à la fois un
peuples colonisateurs et un peuple
colonisé et selon moi ce sera peut être
aidant pour les premières nations du
fait que histoire qu'est ce que c'est
d'être colonisé des fois faut leur
rappeler
des fois ils connaissent pas tous
honnêtement il ya encore un gros travail
d'éducation à faire à l'intérieur de
tous les partis politiques province on
l'a vu cette semaine avec monsieur
legault qui parlait de communauté et
dessous communauté et donc mais ça je
pense qu'une sensibilité là qui va être
autre que la porte elle est ouverte
j'allais senti d'ailleurs dans le
discours de monsieur blanchet il a salué
les premières nations et les inuits le
soir des élections
il a parlé d'une relation à rebâtir un
lien de confiance à rebâtir et j'y crois
beaucoup et j'ai encore une fois
beaucoup d'espoir qu'est ce que vous
voulez ce que fait comme dans les
communautés inuit est ce que c'est la
même chose est-ce qu'on a intérêt aussi
à se tourner vers vers les partis
minoritaires
oui mais je veux juste ajouter pour le
bloc québécois une autre chose dans le
contexte les inuits au québec
oui il dit aussi qu avec le bloc y ait
beaucoup de sensibilité sur les
questions de langue l'importance de
l'anglais protection des langues
celui dit dans des dossiers comme le
servis d'eux
en inuit au québec que aussi avec le
bloc québécois il ya vraiment les gènes
de compréhension qui qui qui aide
beaucoup dans ces dossiers là où un clic
et alors on va se revoir la prochaine
fois le 22 novembre puisque le 20
novembre le parti libéral dont justin
trudeau va former son nouveau
gouvernement
la question intéressante et qui parmi
les autochtones qui ont été élus à
travers le pays sont ministrable qui
pourrait devenir ministre dans le parti
libéral du canada mais n'y seulement
quand même deux candidats autochtones
sous la bannière libérale qui ont été
rudes en lice on l'a dit dit députés et
oui mais seulement de l'exacte donc
c'est yvonne jones qui est une innocuité
lui d'un labrador et marque serrée qui
est un qui vient de d'un orgue b mattawa
donc inefficace qui est intéressant
quand même c'est que c'est un franco
ontarien et il est aussi rattachée à une
première nation donc il a un peu une
double minorité oui bon je pense que ça
pourrait être intéressant c'est
quelqu'un qui a travaillé au service aux
entreprises pendant longtemps
oui donc ils sont différents comités
aussi au niveau du gouvernement fédéral
peut-être que là il pourrait avoir une
opportunité intéressante mais sinon ben
oui je vous aurais dit je vous dis mais
on oublie ça le choisir un ministre qui
est en dehors nous comme aux autres
maintenant évidemment il ya 2 enfin peu
de chance en effet on arrive
attendu coalition ben c'est une autre
élue candidate à qui on est et qui ont
remporté le npd compte dans nos parodies
de winnipeg sun piscine à boules pour un
bijou intéressant ça fait comment des
gens du 9 août
c'est comme mon ami nous c'est important
de bien connaître selon lui je suis à
peu près j'ai appris à ne pas danser
explique alors vous disiez oui pour un
oui pour un non seulement une minute
parce que peut-être qu'à 25 ans on la
trouve wilson quelque chose mais bon il
reste que l'influencé que peut avoir
dans un npd qui va avoir à appuyer le
gouvernement qui va avoir la négocier
lors son appui au gouvernement comme les
magasins pourraient faire en sorte qu'on
ait deux femmes très influente très
influent mais pourrait on va voir
justement ça va être quoi la place du
npd de dans ce gouvernement minoritaire
et léo gaza si je me trompe pas c'est
quand même la conjointe dormait au salon
qu'il ya peut-être quelque chose là il
ya une ouverture de la part de monsieur
trudeau sur justement la déclaration des
nations unies bon de faire mieux avec
saddam finalement passé le projet de loi
c'est trop pour la définir afin que la
femme de
voilà c'est un combat qui a mené son
conjoint et je pense qu'elle va le
reprendre du côté du côté du nord est ce
qu'il y aurait des inuit qui aurait
intérêt plus présents au parlement
canadien
mais cessons mais ces questions du
cabinet c'est intéressant parce qu'ils
vendent jambes et les hyènes député très
expérimenté et les loups dans impartiale
en 2013 2015 prix maintenant mais dans
le maritime ses traits comme beaucoup de
monde je sais pas être choisi et je
pense que dans le gouvernement y ait
besoin d'un député dans le nom dans les
cabinets il ya les rues d'haguenau qu'il
était lui aux yeux quand il y mettra aux
deux outils et nos peut-être mais ces
acquis qui se règle comme je pense le
mieux classé mais on va voir on va voir
et évidemment il faudra choisir un
nouveau ministre des affaires
autochtones à une ministre des affaires
autochtones qui vous qui voyez vous dans
la mire
qui aimeriez-vous voir qui aurait les
compétences pour être là j'aurais envie
de répondre un autochtone je pense qu'il
serait temps mais en même temps c'est un
gros mandat pour un autochtone j'en
doute match tout à double sens
exactement vraiment djoudi voulait pas
de ce possible
je voulais faut être c'est le cas les
discriminer ou qu'elle est belle oui la
loi sur les indiens
donc c'est un peu et c'est quelque chose
de très très très difficile a demandé je
pense exactement ce que j'allais dire
parce que justin martin couteau à double
tranchant
alors est-ce que seamus o'regan a
suffisamment fait du bon travail depuis
qu'il a été mise en poste là pour
continuer ce travail là s'il est choisi
de nouveaux est ce que ça pourrait être
lui là je vous invite à faire des
suggestions au premier ministre
j'espère qu'il est en écoute à l'écouté
de ce que vous allez lui recommander
aimons du jeu la question est oui oui
c'est embêtant parce que je trouve que
leur il faut travailler beaucoup sont au
niveau de la réconciliation et ont fait
fort au niveau des services mais on a vu
ce que ça a donné en bout de ligne et
vous aviez raison sur le terrain on voit
pas toujours les résultats
donc est ce que bon de scinder le
ministère des forêts et en deux ce que
ç'a vraiment été aidé en est ce que
madame bennett c'est ça je trouve que là
quand même à le faire un travail
intéressant je les sens sincère je les
sens si forte
je trouvais qu'il y avait une voie il y
avait il y avait des canaux le qui passe
et ça n'a pas été parfait mais quand
même je trouvais ça intéressant oui
de l'autre côté j'ai senti ça peut être
un petit peu plus froid
c'est ma perception des choses je les
les moins jeunes les moins sensibles
près après des gens près du peuple
je sais pas si avec ce qu'on voudrait
que ça devienne si c'est la bonne
personne je pose certaines insultes
bien-être fait un certain travail il ya
dans la relation on le vus présentes sur
le terrain après ce pour le poste de
service le kiwayu et qu'ils vont
appliquer la loi sur les indiens et
appuyer tous les services de sans abri
c'est plutôt raté
isabelle g j'ai pas de personne à sortir
de mon chapeau war pour cette position
là parce que c'est un travail aussi plus
technique
je pense que madame jeannette elle a
travaillé plus dans le symbolique qui à
l'époque est un mauvais travail là donc
on devrait peut-être pas savoir conduire
mais pour le travail qui est de
l'application plus technique
un autochtone pour être intéressant
aussi parce qu'il pourrait comprendre
qu'est-ce que vécue puis thomas commence
à s'impliquer dans réalité comment
comment le vit sur le terrain peut-être
à cet égard ou si c'est pas un
autochtone justement parce que ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure c'est beaucoup
beaucoup de pression vu le système match
était rome est d'avoir au minimum une
personne un ministre qui a travaillé
avec des premières nations avec des
inuits qui sait qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une sensibilité direct du terrain on
peut plus avoir quelqu'un qui vient de
je sais pas où le métier une ville où il
est absolument pas de docteur que jamais
travaillé avec les autochtones ont le
déjà-vu communes et des affaires
autochtones
ça n'a pas de sens sapin straw poll il
sera également l'occasion vont être
fermées ou une ministre des affaires
autochtones pour les deux là
mais je vous pensais alors on dort là
dessus on attend le 20 novembre
on regarde tout ça et on s'en reparle 22
normes on va analyser donc les choix qui
aura été fait par le gouvernement
libéral
merci à tous les trois oui oui vous
savez que la semaine prochaine
en fait ce week end c'est le gala de
l'adisq il ya une catégorie autochtone
cinq artistes autochtones donc sont dans
cette catégorie 1 sera choisie comme
l'artiste autochtone de l'année alors on
espère la voir
vendredi prochain ici à l'émission alors
isabelle préparez-vous on écoute les
happy hogan et deux félix ya oui
exactement en or elle est en bonne
position mais y en a 5 on les aime tous
les cinq donc on leur souhaite à tous
les 5 bonnes chances et donc nous aurons
sûrement 1-2 peut être plus nous verrons
donc la semaine prochaine
merci encore une fois d'avoir été là et
à votre 10 prochains
[Musique]